puede haber muchas cosas que estén
unidas a una cadena principal de
carbonos y en este vídeo quiero
hablarles de los saludos de alquilo
haluros
de alquilo
aquí tenemos una situación en donde hay
más de un halógeno en una misma cadena
los halógenos están a la derecha de la
tabla periódica y son los elementos como
el flúor cloro y bromo y yodo los
saludos de alquilo o también llamados
halogenuros de alquilo son cadenas en
donde algunos de estos elementos
sustituye a un hidrógeno que estaba
unido al carbono aquí les he dibujado
algunos saludos de alquilo quiero que
pensemos un poco en su nomenclatura así
como nombramos a las moléculas orgánicas
aquí también se debe buscar primero a la
cadena más larga y esa cadena más larga
debe incluir al doble enlace si es que
hay alguno en este caso no hay un doble
enlace así que la cadena más larga se ve
así podemos empezar por aquí o por acá
pero empecemos por aquí
tenemos al carbono 12
8 carbonos vamos a revisarlo 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 y 8 y debemos empezar la numeración
desde donde tengamos algún sustituye
ente que no sea un hidrógeno empezaremos
desde este lado aquí está el carbono 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 y 8 así que tenemos un octano
octano ahora veamos los diferentes
halógenos que están unidos a esta cadena
aquí tenemos un cloro unido al carbono 2
entonces tenemos al 2 cloro
y cómo hay que respetar el orden
alfabético podemos ponerlo antes del
octano porque de este lado en el carbono
tenemos un bromo 4 bromo
como la vez va antes que la ce el bromo
iría primero pero aún nos falta un
sustituye ente para esta molécula no
sólo tenemos halógenos sino que también
tenemos un grupo metilo aquí está en el
carbono 5 tenemos un grupo metilo no
debemos olvidarlo así que es el 5 metilo
escribamos entonces el nombre completo
para esta molécula lo pondré abajo
tomando en cuenta el orden alfabético
empezamos con la letra de 4 bromo
después está la letra c 2 cloro y
finalmente 5 metilo
octano
nos quedó 4 bromo 2 cloro 5 metil
octanos ahora si observamos la otra
estructura nuestra cadena principal es
solamente de 2 carbonos y como están
unidos por un enlace simple tenemos un
metano
veamos que otros grupos o elementos
están unidos a esta cadena como pueden
ver en este carbono se sustituyeron
todos los hidrógenos por halógenos todos
ellos son el elemento flúor podemos
empezar por este carbono ya que tiene
más sustituye entes entonces en este
caso tenemos 123 átomos de flor en este
carbono
este es el carbono 1 y este es el 2 para
el carbono 1 mejor cambiar de color
tenemos 123 átomos de flor será tri flor
y como están unidos al carbono 1
entonces nos queda uno como 1,13 flor
ahora vamos con el carbono 2 unido a
este
tenemos el bromo entonces tenemos 2
bromo
y también tenemos un cloro es el dos
cloro
tomando en cuenta el orden alfabético la
letra be para primero y luego la c y
finalmente el tri flor ignoramos el tri
pero por la letra f nos queda al final
entonces tenemos al 2 bromo usaré los
mismos colores
promo
2 cloro
1 1 1 3 flúor
three flúor eta no
ahora me gustaría hablarles de lo que
ocurre cuando hay un doble enlace en
vídeos anteriores ya lo habíamos visto
cuando hablamos sobre el que nos vimos
un poco pero quiero que lo veamos
nuevamente usemos esta molécula de
arriba le pondré un doble enlace por
aquí digamos que tenemos un doble enlace
justo aquí y todo cambia para esta
molécula pues ya no tenemos un octano
sino un octano en esta situación ahora
empezamos la numeración por el lado
izquierdo porque debemos iniciar lo más
cerca al doble enlace entonces tenemos
7 y 8 ahora tenemos al 7 cloro
este es el 5 bromo
este es el 4 metido lo escribiré por acá
tomando en cuenta el orden alfabético
ahora tenemos al 5 bromo
7 cloro
4 me til
y luego ponemos el ok
como es un al que no debemos especificar
en donde empieza el doble enlace en este
caso empieza en el carbono 2 entonces a
y qué tal si le pongo otro doble enlace
ahora tenemos dos dobles enlaces un
carbono no puede tener más de cuatro
enlaces aquí había tres y uno que estaba
unido a un hidrógeno pero ahora tenemos
un doble enlace y en lugar de ser 12 en
o como ahora tenemos otro doble enlace
empieza en el carbono 4 entonces tenemos
el off 2
4 y al ser dos dobles enlaces ahora es
un relleno
así que tenemos al 5 bromo 7 cloro 4
metí a 24 lleno
y todo esto se los he mencionado
nuevamente para mostrarles que cuando
tenemos un doble enlace debemos iniciar
la numeración de la cadena lo más cerca
de donde se encuentre y que cuando
tenemos más de un doble enlace debemos
especificar cuántos son para este caso
que eran dos le pusimos div